internet service providers were not willy nilly blocking traffic and throttling traffic.
To the contrary, these were all phantoms that were conjured up
by people who wanted the FCC for political reasons to over-regulate the internet.
Hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason and today we are talking with Ajit Pai.
He's the chairman of the Federal Communications Commission,
which oversees the licensing of radio and television stations,
creates ownership roles for certain types of media companies,
polices broadcast radio and television for indecency,
and over the past few years has tried to enforce controversial rules
that will maintain a free and open internet, sometimes called net neutrality.
Ajit, thanks for talking to us.
Nick, great to be with you again.
You are repealing Title II rules,
explain what that will do and what you hope to accomplish with that.
Well, as you pointed out, Title II involves the panoply of heavy-handed economic regulations
that were developed in the Great Depression to handle Ma Bell, the telephone monopoly of the 1930s.
My previous colleagues imposed those rules on the internet,
one of the most dynamic systems we've ever known.
Earlier I proposed to my fellow commissioners at the FCC
to repeal those Title II regulations.
Going forward, my hope is that in a more free market, light touch environment,
we can figure out what the right regulatory framework is
to preserve those core protections of a free and open internet
that have existed prior to 2015 when on a party-line vote, the FCC adopted these net neutrality regulations.